para muchos en mianmar facebook es
internet una nueva demanda colectiva
acusa a la plataforma de redes sociales
de desempeñar un papel directo en una
campaña de limpieza étnica contra los
rohingyas el núcleo de esta demanda de
la constatación de que facebook estaba
dispuesto a cambiar la vida de los
rohingyas por una mejor penetración en
el mercado de un pequeño país del
sudeste asiático
la demanda afirma que aunque la
persecución contra la minoría musulmana
continúa durante años el panorama cambió
drásticamente una vez que facebook entró
en escena en 2012 con un algoritmo
diseñado para promover contenidos
polarizantes ayudó a radicalizar a los
usuarios en mianmar de alimento la
violencia en el mundo real
facebook es como un robot programado con
una única misión crecer y la realidad
innegable es que el crecimiento de
facebook alimentado por el odio la
división y la desinformación ha dejado a
sus pasos cientos de miles de vida rojin
ya devastadas ya en 2018 investigadores
de derechos humanos de la onu dijeron
que facebook había jugado un papel clave
en el genocidio rojin ya interrogado en
el congreso de eeuu el fundador de la
red social mark zuckerberg prometió
tomar medidas
estamos poniendo en pie un equipo de
producto para hacer cambios específicos
en llamar y en otros países que puedan
tener problemas similares en el futuro
para evitar que esto ocurra pero el
discurso de odio continuó y hace sólo
unas semanas la denunciante francés
joven testificó que facebook estaba
alimentando a sabiendas la violencia
étnica según la legislación
estadounidense el gigante de las redes
sociales está ampliamente protegido de
la responsabilidad por los contenidos
publicados por sus usuarios sin embargo
los abogados que representan a los
refugiados rohingya afirman que están
demandando en virtud de la legislación
mi hermana que no tiene esa disposición